we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p our friend the
eggman called in
he's starting to think maybe there
really is a deep state listen to this
hey guys is there legitimately a deep
state
okay think about it okay just recently
joe rogan and
uh
uh
alex jones both are starting coming out
for desantis on their radio shows okay
okay these radio programs that are
national that have this right wing
leaning that have very low iq listeners
and low iq speakers right true who are
all starting to pop up to santa's
defense all over is somebody controlling
that is somebody leaving that that's a
republican deep state that's a right
wing deep state there's more evidence of
that no there's none i made it up but
there's more evidence of that than a
democrat deep state one of the dems say
who's controlling all this media who's
causing the media to flip from trump to
desantis yeah somebody's controlling
this there's a right wing deep state who
is it whose hand is on the button
i think the dems need to change the way
we talk about this stuff okay there's
something going on or maybe it's not i
don't know
shalom
all right shalom to the eggman yeah the
eggman's completely right i mean just
like imagine a different scenario okay
imagine the scenario the real world
right now which is joe biden's the
president and again we don't know if joe
biden's running for re-election we just
don't know right now
imagine if all of a sudden
every left-wing show you you turn on
this show and i'm talking about you know
just whoever just makes something
hillary clinton like this actually is
the perfect example imagine that you
turn on the david pakman show
and i am for some reason talking about
how
i think it's over for biden and we need
to get hillary to be the 24 nominee and
then you turn on msnbc
and they're saying it's time for hillary
to come back
and you turn on tom hartman and tom's
saying we've got to draft hillary
clinton or whatever
of course these right wingers would
immediately say this is evidence of the
deep state somehow even though biden's
president you are seeing a coordinated
and calculated effort to rehabilitate
and resuscitate hillary clinton's
political career to make her the 2024
nominee it's the bilderbergs it's the
trilateral commission it's the
illuminati it's the you know whatever
whatever you want to say uh it might get
worse they it might get anti-semitic as
well
and yet it's actually true that from
somewhere there's a movement coming that
is starting to question donald trump's
place at the top of the the republican
party and question trump's
assumed
2024 nomination if he wants it and
they're starting to talk about ron
desantis they're not talking about
anybody else they're not talking about
nikki haley they're not talking about
lindsey graham or
you know whoever they're talking about
ron desantis
and the reason that the left doesn't go
it's a deep state conspiracy it's
because it's absurd
it's absurd what's going on is there are
lots of people who never like trump and
there's still a significant number of
people in the republican party who
publicly go along with trump just
doesn't make them good people by the way
they publicly go along with trump
because they saw the way the tide was
turning and they see the way the wind's
blowing now for now still but they would
rather someone else they believe that
trump has been damaging to the party and
so they'd rather someone else and right
now that's someone else most pointedly
seems to be ron desantis that's it we we
don't go to deep state because there's
no evidence of that and of course it
would be the same thing if all of a
sudden the left started uniting around
someone else even though biden's the
president but the right would
immediately say it's a conspiracy it's a
deep state you're taking your
direction from soros or whoever else
it's going to be uh very very good point
by the eggman we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today we now have polling
do americans support canceling student
debt a majority do now that doesn't mean
that that's the reason to do it
most people if you go to them and you
say hey would you like your loans paid
off who's going to say no if you come to
me and you say hey do you you want me to
pay off some
sure i guess pay it off but we don't do
things necessarily just because people
want it done but it is interesting that
a majority of voters support this
political decision made by joe biden and
that may have a political impact we will
discuss
there is a uh there's a drought
happening in much of the country in
california there are water bans drought
restrictions that have been put in place
and a whole bunch of different
celebrities are accused of just
violating it they are flouting it not
flaunting flouting you can look that up
kim kardashian sylvester stallone and
others
we are going to talk about the legal
realities of such water bans on the
bonus show and also i do want to update
you about what's going on with donald
trump's platform truth social truth
essential massive financial problems
much like trump with his own lawyers not
paying a number of different vendors
the days may already be numbered for
truth central and i have to tell you it
would just be delightful if the free
market decided that the platform is
trashed and it's trash and it deserves
to be flushed
that would be an absolutely delightful
thing so i would love for you to join us
on the bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad yeah you're invited to
join us on the bonus show you can sign
up at joinpacman.com
and you have the added benefit if you
were to sign up today that wednesday
we're doing our next
members only
town hall
it will be an exclusive event to
participate in for our members anybody
can watch it'll be streaming live on
youtube tuition facebook but if you want
to participate in the town hall you sign
up at joinpakman.com and of course you
can use the coupon code obama
to get a discount all right sign up we
will see you on the bonus show and i
look forward to seeing you on the town
hall on wednesday